[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you
a birthday present
uh
incredible character that i love
a tale
of
someone trying to steal something
and
an incredible bonding situation
with a lifelong friend that i feel i've
met
today i give you
xm studios
brown suit wolverine
now the odyssey for this statue is
incredible the story that i'm going to
tell you right now is nuts and i thought
i was gonna come in and tell you oh when
he got his first brown suit how he got
it from the phoenix saga by fighting one
of the imperial god and taking a suit
because his uh blue and yellow suit was
in tatters
and he took that guy's suit and he put
it on
uh you know and i thought i was going to
tell you that uh the brown suit made the
debut man uncanny x-men
what is it 139 something like that and
i thought that would be it i would i
would go through that i would tell you
that john byrne is the inspiration for
the cover of
the the polls that he's he's having i
thought i would tell you that no i'm
telling you how
my statue
got to me
so uh i got the statue from a buy sell
trade group uh that's on facebook and
i want to buy sell trade group excuse me
the guy didn't want to ship
so
shout out to my boy mojo
my
mojo was like oh don't worry i'll pick
up the statue and i'll ship the statue
to you so you know send mojo the statue
um
some mojo money uh for the statue and
you know mojo goes and he picks up the
statue and mojo takes the statue you
know home he inspects the stuff and all
that other stuff and you know he really
went out his way and i really appreciate
mojo for doing such a great deed uh
that's where the lifelong friend comes
in
mojo is a great guy a great collector
and i got a chance to meet him just
recently absolutely nice fantastic mojo
i want my picture
um
so
statue ships to me now i have all the
checks and balances that goes through
the ups app
right so when when it ships when it's
loaded on the truck when it's everything
when it's delivered everything i get
text i get email i get everything so i'm
in the gym i'm working out
and it said my statue was delivered
called the house
um no statue here
got to the house because i'm just down
the blocks from the gym parked in the
driveway uh i checked the back i checked
the side no statue
they said the statue assigned for i saw
ups truck drive pass i jumped in the car
shot over there to him
parked in front of the truck
asked him where's my statue you said you
delivered the statue where did you
deliver this attitude at the same time
i'm on the phone with customer service
right putting in a complaint oh the guy
was like oh yeah i delivered i don't
know where i delivered it at complete
lie complete sham ups you got a guy that
you need to worry about right so i'm
following behind the truck because he's
like i'll figure it out um you know um
yeah i delivered it no you know when you
deliver a heavy box out of something you
you understand that you're not
delivering tons of heavy boxes all day
you know so you want you know when you
deliver the big box where and if it's on
this block you can only go but so far
right
okay
anyway i shoot over to the ups store and
you know i tell the manager the manager
come out listen this is where the shiest
is fully in and the manager is like well
you know what you do is you know you put
in a ticket sometimes you know packages
go lost you know but what you do is you
know you just tell the manufacturer and
the manufacturer send you out another
thing i said first of all that's not a
manufacturer first of all it came from
my boy second he's not fitting the bill
for no 1200 statue so
that money is coming out of somebody and
i believe that's your driver so if the
driver doesn't want any issues he
doesn't want any problems
i don't know what to tell you but i
better get my statute
okay all right
um we'll have you you know uh give you
this number to call
and yeah okay
um but i'm pretty sure that your statue
will show up why are you pretty sure my
statue will show up because you're used
to this type of behavior probably more
than likely well lo and behold two hours
later my statue shows up
i.e
wolverine
made it to the humble of old which is
the castle
he made it here so again a fantastic
statue
that was
the story that
took away
the fun aspect that i was going to give
you with brown suit because we were so
in love with yellow suit yellow and blue
suit wolverine but um brown suit has a
special place in my heart and
uh
xm took a lot of liberties when it came
to this statue with certain things and
certain questions that i had uh when it
came to wolverine
well
this
statue actually is on a rooftop in
feudal japan and you can see the samurai
headdress there and you can see the two
samurai swords which is actually posable
in wolverine's hands
you can have either the anti-mattium
claws or you can have the bone claws
here you can have different hand
positions and you can have the sword
holding positions with the claws that go
inside now on these uh positions the
claws go individually inside each
slot and this is the sword holding hand
which is incredible right so
you know
that you can position it very
differently so you can have the claws
coming out you can have bone claws
inside here you can have anti-medium
claws inside there and the claws
look like this
see this is the anti-medium claws and
the bone claws is right here on the side
i will have pictures up and video in the
background it comes with a separate
portrait and a separate portrait is
the portrait of you know wolverine's
face james howlett you know um
we call him logan
because that's what you know him as now
but if you go deeper into his story you
know you get to know who he is and
what's his name about
the costume is heavily textured from the
boots
all the way up to the cowl
what i like about the textures is
varying textures in between because
they're using the brown as a leather
texture they're using
the yellow
as um
kind of like a material texture which
looks very good i like these boots on
this wolverine the most because there's
a zipper part in the back which looks
incredible and i didn't think they would
get that done i always had a question on
how wolverine put his boots on as a kid
and i see now um the belt the red belt
which i never understood why he had a
red belt with the suit but the red belt
is actually done so incredibly different
it looks very nice i love the little
japanese thing that it has on the end of
it the metal piece
looks fantastic
everything all the way up to the cowl is
great then you have the gloves i thought
the gloves was done very well
because it has a double strap that's on
the inside it's just not a regular glove
it actually has some um design work on
it and i believe that's an xm own type
of design and it has straps on it it
looks very good very detailed the
anatomy on wolverine is incredible
i thought that the fish in the back with
the dragon's face
accentuated this statue so well because
it does look like jade and it does look
like a
withered you know marble and stuff like
that this is a highly detailed statue of
wolverine that should fit in anyone's
collection
and it fits in mine
so this is the part of the video where
i'm gonna tell you to like follow and
subscribe and hit that join button hit
that join button you know where that
join button is that join button is right
there down at the bottom hit the join
button so you can join the realm so you
can see what we're doing at iop lords of
gaming.net where we have ton of writers
ton of opinion pieces we have episodes
with the lord's minute we can get to see
laura cognito lord sovereign lord addict
and
lord king david with uh different takes
on different things in life that you may
not know that we talk about or we do so
go there check that stuff out you can
see old episodes of kos there where you
can see uh different statues that i do
have and different statues that i did
talk about so you can see what the
collection is really looking like well
stick around
watch the statue in all its glory and
listen some great music as i do the
unboxing straight for this statue it was
two layers i show pictures and stuff
like that so you can check it out and
you can see how i build the statue in
the background
next week
i'm going to have somebody
that's a little bit dark a little bit
sinister
a little bit
of
[Music]
a lord
stay collected
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
i rule
[Music]
foreign